things are heating up between kourtney
kardashian and travis barker
this is such a dream come true meanwhile
court's ex
scott disick is still adjusting to the
reality star's new relationship
i think we've been through so much a
source tells et that travis is quote
so in love and infatuated with the push
founder
adding that they are having the best
time together
quote he's 100 percent all in and
totally sees a future with her courtney
is living her best life
and is truly so happy i'm just like
living life and whatever happens happens
meanwhile while it comes to courtney's
ex scott disick
who's currently dating 19 year old model
amelia hamlin
the source says it's been an adjustment
for him getting used to court and
travis's serious relationship
quote he is still trying to get used to
it scott is still close with courtney
but things between them have changed a
bit
i mean i think you just gotta figure out
really what's important to you at the
end of the day
both scott and travis wish the 42 year
old keeping up star a happy birthday
over the weekend
scott posting this pic to his insta
story with their three kids
mason penelope and rayne alongside the
text
quote happy birthday to the best mom a
child could ask for
and some more the post came after travis
shared a pda-heavy tribute in honor of
her special day
sharing several cute snaps like these
and writing in the caption
quote i [ __ ] love you you're a
blessing to this world
sweet right well get this travis
recently got court's name
inked on his chest i love it and
well he also included this video in his
birthday tribute to courtney
yeah that's one way to celebrate a
birthday courtney
sucking on travis's finger
anyways a source told et
earlier this month that court is the
happiest she's been in a long time and
her family is thrilled for her
quote courtney's been trying to keep
their relationship as private as she can
on social media
but they're both super into each other
and cute together
[Music]